the most profound discovery of our time
is that our universe had a beginning and
that it's expanding yet the person
responsible for this discovery is
virtually unknown and there's a reason
for it which will become clear je le
metro was a belgian priest who theorized
that the expansion of the universe began
with the explosion of a single particle
at a definite point in time faster than
the speed of light the big bang theory
is accepted by nearly all astronomers
today but back in the 1930s the belief
that the entire observable universe
began with a bang was considered
preposterous even albert einstein found
it far-fetched so how did lumet come up
with this theory
let's go back to the beginning
[Music]
belgium in 1894 to a well-off developing
catholic family he knew what he wanted
to be when he was nine years old both a
priest and a scientist he grew up in a
coal mining region and at the insistence
of his father studied civil mining
engineering at the catholic research
university in the belgian city of luva
only to have his studies interrupted
when germany invaded belgium in 1914. he
left university to fight as an artillery
officer and received the belgian war
cross for bravery on the battlefield at
this time he was already thinking about
the origin of the universe in the
context of his christian faith he wrote
to a friend while in the trenches of war
i've understood the fiat looks as the
reason of the universe fiat looks is
latin for let there be light in
reference to the third verse in the book
of genesis god said let there be light
and there was light after the war he
continued with his education but
switched to mathematics and physics
graduating in 1920 then he went to
seminary school and became ordained as a
priest three years later during this
time he became fascinated by einstein's
general theory of relativity how gravity
can warp space and time which i talked
about in a previous video lumetri then
did postgraduate work at the university
of cambridge under famed english
astronomer sir arthur eddington who had
confirmed einstein's theory when he saw
how gravity bent light from a star
traveling near the sun eddington gave
lumetri a glowing recommendation after
which he spent time at harvard and then
got accepted into a doctoral program at
mit it was a good time to be in the u.s
if you were a scientist because of
recent discoveries that shook people's
understanding of the universe up until
then the milky way which includes our
solar system was thought to be the
entire universe but more powerful
telescopes showed this wasn't true
american astronomer edwin hubble
announced he had evidence the milky way
was one of many galaxies in the universe
he observed that the spiral-shaped
andromeda was in fact a galaxy another
american astronomer vesto slifer noticed
andromeda was bluer in color whereas
other galaxies were redder slifer knew
andromeda was approaching us because of
light is coming toward you the waves get
more squished making the light bluer if
it goes away from you it gets stretched
out making the light waves appear redder
the light of distant galaxies that
appeared to shift more toward the red
end of the color spectrum suggested they
were getting farther away from earth the
belief was that the galaxies were moving
away in a static universe however
lumetra interpreted this red shift
differently he concluded that the
galaxies were not moving away from each
other in a static universe but rather
the universe itself was expanding which
then stretched out the light waves
here's another way to look at it imagine
that this balloon is the universe and
the dots the galaxies as the balloon
expands then the separation between the
dots also expands and from the
perspective of each individual dot or
galaxy it appears that the others are
moving farther away from it an expanding
universe completely shattered the notion
that the universe was static which is
what einstein strongly believed but an
unchanging universe was problematic for
his own theory of relativity if gravity
were the only active force in a static
universe the universe would collapse to
get around this issue einstein added a
cosmological constant presumably a form
of matter or energy that opposes gravity
on the other hand lumetra's expanding
universe would satisfy einstein's theory
of relativity still einstein wasn't
swayed he refused to believe in an
expanding universe lumetra recalled
einstein told him your calculations are
correct but your physics is atrocious
it would take einstein a long time to
come around he did finally abandon his
cosmological constant calling it the
greatest blunder of his life
lumetro returned to europe in 1925 to
take up a teaching post at the catholic
university of louvain where he was
formerly a student in 1927 he published
his case for an expanding universe in
french in a belgian scientific journal
this should have rocked the world but it
didn't no one really paid any attention
to it it wasn't until two years later
when hubble published his own findings
about an expanding universe that the
world took notice hubble measured the
distance of galaxies and also built on
the work of slifer who had measured
redshifts he plotted the distance of
galaxies in their velocities in this
classic graph and showed that more
distant galaxies were moving away from
us faster than galaxies that were closer
and it made sense if the universe were
expanding this became known as hubble's
law he came to the same conclusion as
lumetra yet lementra didn't get any of
the attention and accolades bestowed on
hubble because lumetra had published his
findings in french in an obscure belgian
journal that wasn't widely read outside
of his own country his mentor eddington
is said to have helped arrange an
english translation two years after the
release of hubble's work in 1931.
however the paper omitted limetra's
crucial paragraphs describing hubble's
law turns out lymetra chose to leave
this out himself he reasoned that
hubble's calculations had already
improved on his earlier work he
apparently wasn't fussed at proving that
he had come up with the expansion theory
before hubble he was a humble man who
didn't mind that hubble got the glory
instead lumetra moved forward with his
research and published a new paper in
1931 in which he argued that if the
universe were expanding then it also had
a beginning he proposed this in his
hypothesis of the primeval atom a
primeval atom was a single particle he
argued that the universe began with the
explosion of the single particle that
gave birth to our entire cosmos and
concluded a creation-like event had
occurred researchers date the event to
more than 13.8 billion years ago he
didn't call it the big bang astronomer
sir fred hoyle coined the term during a
talk broadcast on the bbc hoyle actually
thought the theory was nonsense many
scientists were skeptical including
einstein however in 1933 when lametre
and einstein traveled together to attend
a series of seminars in california
elemetra had time to explain his theory
in detail einstein is purported to have
said this is the most beautiful and
satisfactory explanation of creation to
which i have ever listened le metzkel
was nominated for the nobel prize in
physics in 1954 for his prediction of
the expanding universe two years later
he was nominated for the nobel prize in
chemistry for his primeval atom theory
he didn't win either the strongest
evidence supporting the big bang was
discovered by accident a decade later in
1964 by american scientists arno penzias
and robert wilson who were working for
bell laboratories the research and
development arm of what is today nokia
they were baffled by a strange signal
noise picked up by this antenna and
tried to figure out what it was they
even removed some pigeons that were
nesting there that's when they stumbled
upon cosmic microwave background
radiation ancient light thought to be
left over from the big bang lametre
lived to see the moment of their
discovery his ideas were finally
vindicated he died two years later in
1966 from leukemia at the age of 71.
despite not being as arguably well known
as his fellow scientists he is finally
getting more recognition in 2018 the
hubble law was changed to the hubble la
metro law
la metro may have helped uncover the
secrets of the universe yet the more we
learn the stranger it gets
scientists thought that the expansion of
the universe would gradually slow down
over time as gravity put on the brakes
but surprisingly they found the opposite
turns out the expansion of the universe
is accelerating some mysterious force is
driving our universe apart and we don't
know why perhaps in time this mystery
will also be solved this video is
sponsored by skillshare skillshare is
like the netflix of educational videos
it's an online learning community where
you get access to thousands of classes
on a variety of topics you can learn how
to edit videos how to speak confidently
on camera and if you like to
procrastinate there's a class on how to
be more productive there's literally
something for everyone each class is
broken up into short sections and there
are no tests they're great if you're a
beginner or if you'd like to brush up on
your skills skillshare is free for you
to try out for a month if you use my
custom link in the description thanks so
much for watching i hope you enjoyed it
if you did don't forget to subscribe and
give it a like for news think i'm cindy
pomp ah you're so cute this fella says
thanks as well
[Music]